Speaker 1: Every once in a while, I like to come
back to what is a really disturbing reality in the
United States, which is the tax exempt nature,
not only of sort of like churches generally or
of the schools within churches, but even radical
extremist dangerous churches. Having this benefit
from the government wherein they do not pay taxes
of many kinds, including sometimes taxes on the
properties that they own, income taxes on proceeds
received, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. And
there is really no better example of
this than global vision Bible Church
in Tennessee, where, if that sounds familiar, we
have talked about it before, where Pastor Greg
Locke recently went on an outrageous, febrile
screed where he said not only are there six
bona fide witches in our congregation. He said
three of them are in the room right now. OK.
This is this is sanctioned by the state in
the sense that it is a tax exempt endeavor.
Take a look at this. We got first
Speaker 2: and last names of six witches that
are in our church. And you know what's strange?
Three of you are in this room right now, right?
Three of you in the room right now. You. Look at
my eyeballs, we ain't afraid. Are you stinking?
Which you devil worshiping Satan is which
Speaker 1: this is this is dark ages stuff.
This is dark ages. Think about the track record
of the United States when it comes to accusations
of witchcraft. Right? I mean, there's there's
precedent here and this is reminiscent of a very,
very bad time in Salem, Massachusetts.
Speaker 2: We cast you out in the name
of Jesus Christ. We break your spells. We break
your curse. We got your first name. We got your
last name. We even got an address for one of you.
Speaker 1: Now the address part should frighten
all of us because, you know, I mean, let's
you know, you don't need to think too far
about what is being threatened. When you when
you say, address now, it's easy to write this
off as this is one lunatic. And of course, it
is a lunatic. But this is a tax exempt church,
and he's making open threats here on, you
know, which witchcraft? Give me a break, guys.
Speaker 2: You so much as call from expulsion
for anybody on this team, you stink in which
you are sent to this church to destroy
us. You were sent to this church
to lure us here. You were sent to this church
to cast a spell this summer. Are you been
sick because you befriended that witch claiming?
Speaker 1: But that's by the way, this is this is
a covert crazy guy. He called it a fake pandemic
in December of 2020. He turned on Trump when Trump
started saying, Hey, the vaccines pretty good
completely turned on Trump at that time. So
what he's even saying there is those of you who
think you got COVID. You have to understand that
what this guy's talking about, those of you who
believe you got COVID, that you were sick, you had
symptoms. It wasn't COVID, it was witchcraft.
Speaker 2: Well, if you hear my wife's
lady's Bible study and you know who
you are and we go ask you to get out
or expose you and find everybody. We got
all six of their names. All six of them.
Two of them had already been confirmed.
For that thing. Everyone said it. Yeah.
First at last, this check is new to
our church and don't know none of you,
so you've got a choice. You can leave
with your spells all by yourself,
or I'll show up next Sunday with a stage
full of brooms, and I'll give you one and
I'll fly your tail up out of this place in
the name of Jesus, but we ain't playing your
spell casting witchcraft nonsense.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, you know,
if we want to take this pragmatically,
we would all be saying, You know,
if you're praying to Jesus, the right way isn't
that stronger than the witchcraft? Like, can't do
you need to kick them out to resist the spells? Or
could you maybe just pray right? And then God will
protect you from the smooth, stronger the witches
of it? None of it makes sense. This is a guy
who's running a church with a transphobic,
homophobic climate change, denying COVID
denying record. He posted a video back in
August of 2020, threatening violence against
the Dunkin Donuts employee, who he referred to
as Nazi Skippy. Because the employee was like,
Hey, we have a mask policy here. Well, you got
it. You got to wear a mask here. Global Vision
Bible Church in Tennessee, tax exempt. Think about
how backwards this all is in the United States.